[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duels au sommaire
aujourd'hui deux soeurs jumelles qui
sont nées de la guerre froide me qui ont
évolué différemment la république
démocratique allemande et la république
fédérale d'allemagne
séparés à la naissance elles sont
devenus par la suite des adversaires
géopolitique et se sont livrés une
bataille idéologique pendant presque
quarante ans
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation des dirigeants les plus
emblématiques de la rfa et de la rda
c'est le blitz conrad adenauer naît le 5
janvier 1876 à cologne fils d'un
greffier grâce à une bourse il fait des
études de droit à l'université de
fribourg puis de munich et enfin de
bonnes et entame une carrière juridique
en 1901 nombre du parti catholique qui
est un trouble adenauer intègre le
conseil municipal de cologne à 1906
trois ans plus tard il devient adjoint
au maire de la ville puis en 1917 et
prend sa place de 1921 1933 il est
également président du conseil d'état de
prusse à l'accession des nazis au
pouvoir il est destitué de ses fonctions
et se retire dans sa maison familiale
walter ulbricht nea lipsic le 30 juin
1893 fils d'un tailleur pauvres après
l'école primaire il devient menuisier à
l'âge de 19 ans une brique tu entres
parti social-démocrate le spd auquel
adhèrent ses parents après la première
guerre mondiale où il est mobilisé il
retourne à l'éthique et participe à la
création de la section locale du parti
communiste allemand le kpd en 1923 il
intègre le comité central est élu au rex
tag en 1928 à partir de 1933 il quitte
l'allemagne nazie pour paris prague puis
moscou en 1938 où il travaille pour le
komintern l'internationale communiste à
la fin de la guerre conrad adenauer et
rétablit en tant que maire de cologne
par les forces américaines il s'engage
alors au sein de l'union chrétienne
démocrate la cdi créé la même année qui
réunit catholiques et protestants
adenauer en devient le président dans la
zone britannique en 1946 en septembre
1949 adenauer est élu chancelier fédéral
de la nouvelle ère et femme par le
groupe parlementaire constitué par la
cdu et l'union chrétienne sociale de
bavière en 1945 une brique trop vient en
allemagne dans la zone d'occupation
soviétique et contribue à la refondation
du parti communiste allemand en 46 c est
créer le parti socialiste unifié
d'allemagne le sd résultant de la fusion
forcée en zone soviétique du parti
communiste et du parti social-démocrate
à partir de 1949 le nouveau parti
concentre le pouvoir en rda grâce à un
système de liste unique aux élections
walter ulbricht secrétaire général du
comité central du s&ed à partir de 1950
exerce alors le pouvoir réel
tout juste après la proclamation de la
rda son président willem iec propose une
coopération à un but de rapprocher le
plus possible les deux parties de
l'allemagne la réponse du chancelier
fédéral ne laisse pas de place au
compromis seule la rfa a le droit de
parler au nom du peuple allemand dès
lors leur rivalité ne fera que prendre
de l'ampleur économie idéologie
technologies tous les domaines sont
concernés
côté diplomatique la rda est intégré
dans le bloc soviétique alors que la rfa
coopère étroitement avec les pays de
l'europe occidentale et surtout avec les
états unis dans les années soixante dix
la détente fait fondre la glace dans les
relations bilatérales
cependant la crise interne qui éclate en
urss à la fin des années 80 affaibli les
positions soviétique en rda résultat la
destruction du mur de berlin et la
réunification des deux allemagnes
comment cette rivalité at elle marqué le
paysage géopolitique de l'époque
pourquoi la rda at elle finalement cédé
à la pression de la rfa enfin quels
défis l'allemagne moderne at-elle
héritées du passé pour répondre à toutes
ces questions nous rejoignons henri
mennecier professeur honoraire des
universités à paris iii sorbonne
nouvelle germanistes monsieur menuisier
bonjour bonjour tout d'abord pensez vous
qu'il aurait été possible de conserver
l'unité de l'allemagne après la seconde
guerre mondiale ou la division est elle
inévitable oui je crois qu'il aurait été
tout à fait possible de conserver cette
unité après 1945 si les quatre
puissances victorieuses avait vraiment
voulu le stand et coopérer cette
perspective semblait d'ailleurs réaliste
lors de la conférence de yalta en
février 1945 entre staline roosevelt et
churchill c'est d'ailleurs au cours de
cette même conférence que ses dirigeants
politiques ont décidé de créer une
organisation internationale très
importante l'onu organisation des
nations unies à new york la conférence
de yalta en fait conduit un partage du
monde en zone d influence qui ont été
déterminées par les avancées des
différentes armées contre contre
l'allemagne mais les intérêts et les
objectifs divergents des vainqueurs ont
provoqué la formation de deux camps le
camp soviétique dominé par l'urss
s'étendait jusqu'à l'allemagne de l'est
là que le camp occidental avec la france
et la grande bretagne étaient dominés
par les états unis d'amérique ainsi j'ai
installé une coupure est ouest qui a
divisé l'europe l'allemagne et berlin on
a parlé du rideau de fer et de la guerre
froide est-ce que selon vous les
dirigeants des deux allemagne ont joué
un rôle important dans leurs
confrontations ou mehdi teale que des
pions dans la lutte générale entre les
camps des capitalistes et socialiste
pendant les années d'occupation total
entre 1945 et 1949 que les dirigeants
politiques des deux allemagnes
n'entretenait pas de contact
il n'existait pas d'état allemand à
cette époque la vie locale et régionale
se développer simplement haut niveau aux
niveaux locaux au niveau local ou bien
régional est sous la tutelle des alliés
dans chacune des quatre zones
d'occupation
chaque allemagne à l'est et à l'ouest a
pris une orientation idéologique et
politique différente qui ne favorise
naturellement pas le dialogue
l'allemagne de l'est étaient soumises à
la prépondérance du parti communiste
allemand devenu le est rude et
l'allemagne de l'ouest a très vite fait
le choix du libéralisme et de la
démocratie de type occidental
donc le problème des deux états
allemands fondée en 1949 a été
d'accueillir que un peu une autonomie
vis-à-vis des alliés et à l'intérieur du
camp auquel auxquels ils la partagent
appartenait le dialogue politique entre
les deux allemagnes a commencé
véritablement en 1969 avec le chancelier
willy brandt c'est ce qu'on appelait
lost politique merci beaucoup monsieur
ménudier nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouvons la fin de cette émission pour
plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore pendant plus de quarante ans les
relations entre les deux allemagne ont
été marquée par la rivalité la
confrontation c'est la conséquence de la
défaite complète de l'allemagne nazie
dans la seconde guerre mondiale et sa
partition par les alliés de la coalition
anti hitler après la seconde guerre
mondiale les quatre états vainqueur
l'urss les etats-unis la grande-bretagne
et la france 10 vise l'ex reich allemand
en quatre zones
soviétique à l'est américaines
britanniques et françaises à l'ouest
berlin enclavé dans la zone soviétique
est aussi divisée l'urss contrôler la
partie orientale les trois autres la
partie occidentale
l'allemagne est gouvernée par un conseil
de contrôle spécial réunissant les
représentants des quatre pays alliés
pourtant au fur et à mesure que la
tension monte entre l'urss et les états
unis les divisions deviennent de plus en
plus prononcé entre la zone d'occupation
soviétique et celle des pays occidentaux
en 1947 les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne et la france unissent
leurs zones d'occupation en un ensemble
économique la trisomie en plus tard il y
introduisent une nouvelle monnaie le
deutsche mark en réponse l'urss mène
aussi une réforme monétaire dans sa zone
d'occupation et décrète en 1947 un
blocus à berlin qui va durer jusqu'en
mai 1948 en mai 1949 la république
fédérale d'allemagne est proclamé cinq
mois plus tard le parlement provisoire
de l'allemagne de l'est le vol scammeurs
c'est à dire la chambre du peuple
annonce la création de la république
démocratique allemande avec le soutien
de moscou au fil du temps la possibilité
d'une réunification s'éloigne de plus en
plus les deux états développent de
modèle politique et économique
absolument différent état fédéral selon
sa loi fondamentale l'allemagne de
l'ouest avait un système politique basé
sur le multipartisme deux partis
principaux ils sont en concurrence le
parti social démocrate d'allemagne et
l'union chrétienne démocrate d'allemagne
au contraire l'allemagne de l'est est un
état unitaire et centralisée avec un
système politique proche de celui de
l'urss
le parti socialiste unifié d'allemagne
deux mines la scène politique dans le
domaine économique la différence est
encore plus prononcée la rfa adopte un
modèle économique de marché introduit sa
propre monnaie le deutsche mark et
bénéficier du soutien américain dans le
cadre du plan marshall tous ces facteurs
ont contribué à un redressement rapide
de l'allemagne de l'ouest le miracle sur
le rhin c'est ainsi que le quotidien
britannique times qualifié les succès
économiques de la rfa l'alma de l'est
elle suit l'exemple soviétique dans la
construction de son système économique
économie planifiée collectivisation dans
le domaine agricole et nationalisation
des industries contrairement à son
voisin occidental à r d à peine à
retrouver l'équilibré économique les
pénuries devienne le quotidien des
habitants de l'est certains blâment le
système de gestion soviétique alors que
les autres pointent du doigt les
conditions économiques inéquitable en
1953 la rda est secoué par une
contestation populaire qui exigent la
démission du gouvernement et parfois le
départ des troupes soviétiques les
autorités répondent par une dispersion
brutale des manifestations et en font
incomber la responsabilité à la rfa et
aux américains qui auraient envoyé leur
agent 1 er d'air ces événements ne font
qu'amplifier l'exode des habitants de
l'allemagne de l'est vers l'ouest ce
problème qui existe depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale frappe la main
d'oeuvre de la rda selon les estimations
les plus modestes de l'allemagne de
l'est plus de deux millions de personnes
ont préféré l'ouest à l'est entre 49 et
1960 afin d'empêcher les migrations des
personnes la rda déploie en 1952 des
patrouilles renforcées long de la
frontière avec la rfa et autorise à
ouvrir le feu sur les habitants qui
veulent fuir c'est à ce moment là que
les flux migratoires se déplace vers
berlin où le passage entre la partie
orientale et occidentale reste peu
réglementé pourtant dès 1961 cette voie
n'est plus accessible dans la nuit du 12
au 13 août le mur de berlin est érigée
devenant l'un des symboles les plus
forts de la guerre froide à part les
migrations de main d'oeuvre la mise en
place de ce mur permet de faire baisser
l'intensité des opérations secrètes
contre la rda
espionnage propagande incendie plusieurs
organisations ouest allemande opèrent
sur le territoire de la rda des sa
proclamation parmi les plus connus
citons le groupe de combat contre
l'inhumanité
le comité des juristes libre la rda
répondent par des opérations pointu de
ses services de renseignement renommée
la stasi il organise par exemple
l'enlèvement de l'un des leaders du
comité des juristes libre à berlin ouest
en 1952 il sera extradé en urss où il se
verra condamné à la peine de mort entre
les deux antagonistes la diplomatie et
le ci occupe une place importante en
1955 la rfa adopte la doctrine einstein
du nom du secrétaire d'état ouest
allemand aux affaires étrangères
l'idée d'empêcher la reconnaissance
internationale de la rd11 promettant la
rupture avec tout état par l'urss qui
nouera des liens diplomatiques avec
berlin est ce la doctrine est appliquée
deux fois en 1957 avec la yougoslavie et
puis en 1963 à l'encontre de cuba alors
comment la détente internationale at
elle affecté les relations entre
l'allemagne de l'ouest et de l'est
pourquoi le mur de berlin est il tombé
comment la réunification des deux
allemagne at elle bouleverser
l'échiquier mondial la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
appartenant à des blocs opposés les deux
allemagnes diffèrent à plusieurs égards
superficie du territoire économie armés
quel est le rapport de force à l'époque
entre la rda est la rfa avant d'aller
plus loin faisons le récap avec 17
millions d'habitants fin 1970 la
population de la république démocratique
allemande constitue seulement le quart
de celle de la république fédérale
d'allemagne la superficie de la rfa
représente plus du double de celle de la
rda sur le plan économique la rda adopte
un système de planification économique
c'est l'état qui joue le rôle clé dans
la vie économique du pays l'allemagne de
l'ouest mènent une politique basée sur
la libre concurrence et l'initiative
privée des entrepreneurs bien que la rda
reste derrière la rfa en termes de
productivité l'allemagne de l'est est à
la sixième place en termes de production
industrielle en europe sur le plan
militaire la rf a créé en octobre 1955
ses propres forces armées appelé le
bundeswehr trois mois plus tard la rda
met en place sa propre armée l'armée
nationale populaire cependant son nombre
selon les données de 1981 n'est que 280
mille soldats contre 495 mille soldats
en rfa en revanche l'allemagne de l'est
un atout de taille son ministère de la
sécurité d'état ou la stasi autrefois
l'un des services de renseignements les
plus puissants du monde les années 60 se
traduisent par un certain dégel des
relations est ouest dans ce contexte à
rda et la rfa font aussi leur premier
pas timide vers la détente en 1963 en
allemagne de l'ouest le parti
social-démocrate énonce une nouvelle
conception de la politique étrangère le
changement par le rapprochement l'idée
est de nouer le dialogue avec l'est en
les sentes pour l'instant de côté la
question de la réunification
la coalition au pouvoir en adopte
quelques éléments toujours en 1963 le
protocole de berlin permet à des
centaines de milliers de berlinois de
l'ouest visiter leurs proches à l'est
pour la première fois depuis la
construction du mur en 1967 pour la
toute première fois la rfa en fran
correspondance officielle avec la rda
ensuite bonne va à l'encontre de la
doctrine einstein et établi des
relations avec la roumanie socialiste
pirro nous avec la yougoslavie et en
1968 les deux allemagnes s'accordent
pour libérer le commerce bilatéral ce
rapprochement s'accélère dès 1969 la
doctrine einstein commence à montrer ses
limites de plus en plus de pays
reconnaissent la rda et l'agenda global
et dominé de plus en plus par la détente
américano soviétique à bonn ce contexte
propice au pouvoir les partisans du
dialogue le parti social démocrate
dès son discours d'investiture le
nouveau chancelier willy brandt annonce
donc un tournant vers l'est une ligne
politique connue sous le nom dost
politique
vingt ans après la fondation de la rfa
et de la rda nous devons empêcher
l'évolution divergente de la nation
allemande en d'autres mots nous devons
tenter de progresser d'abord via une
coexistence harmonieuse vers la cohésion
ce n'est pas un objectif purement
allemand il est aussi important pour la
paix en europe et pour la relation est
ouest très vite les paroles laisse la
place aux actes en novembre l'ouest
renonce formellement aux ambitions
nucléaires
en rejoignant le traité de
non-prolifération
février 1970 la doctrine einstein est
officiellement abandonné cela suffit
pour briser la glace le tout premier
sommet est ouest a lieu en mars mais ne
donne pas de résultats concrets la rd 1
et surtout son chef walter ulbricht
reste méfiant envers l'ostpolitik une
brique tu démissionnes en 1971 c'est à
ce moment là que le dialogue est ouest
décolle vraiment plusieurs traités
ponctuelles sont le signer avant
l'aboutissement du texte le plus
important celui qui en décembre 1972
posera les bases de leur relation les
deux allemagnes se proclame égales en
droit en terrine leurs frontières nous
la coopération et procède à un échange
de représentants sur le plan bilatéral
la normalisation amène à un nouveau
niveau d'intégration des deux états
les relations commerciales sans pacifié
et le volume des échanges ne cesse de
croître vers 1985 il atteint 15,5
milliards de marks ou est-allemand
conscient de sa supériorité économique
bonne subventionne plusieurs projets
d'infrastructure liant l'est et l'ouest
dans l'espoir d'accélérer la voie vers
l'intégration la rfa ne cesse d'élargir
la ligne de crédit accordée à la rda ce
soft power lui permet de décrocher des
concessions notamment dans le domaine
des visas et des échanges humanitaires
ce qui favorise le développement des
contacts au niveau culturel et social
l'établissement de partenariats entre
les universités ou entre les villes des
deux états si berlin est accepte
volontiers ses aspects du rapprochement
sur le plan politique il continue de
s'opposer à l'ouest des contacts
toujours plus nombreux au niveau des
populations et la propagande active de
l'unification allemande par la rfa
pousse la rda à défendre davantage sa
souveraineté ainsi dans les années 70 la
nation allemande dans la constitution
est remplacé par un état socialiste des
ouvriers et paysans dans les noms des
institutions publiques les mots
allemands et allemagne sont remplacés
par rda le mur est sans cesse
perfectionnés et devient de plus en plus
infranchissable est la pression sur les
dissidents montrent les années 80 seront
le dernier chapitre du duel entre les
deux allemagnes en transigeant tu dans
son roger de l'unification la rda
traverse une période difficile qui
préfigure sa chute depuis le début des
années 80 l'allemagne de l'est s'enfonce
dans une crise économique l'écart
technologique s'accentue de plus en plus
et pèse sur la croissance le budget est
en déficit permanent à cause de larges
dépenses sociales la dette publique
s'accumulent a atteint 20,9 milliards de
dollars en 1989 le niveau de vie de
l'est contraste de plus en plus avec
l'ouest capitaliste à ses problèmes
internes s'ajoutent les bouleversements
qui se coule conso cialiste à la fin des
années 80 dès 1987 l'urss se réalise un
tournant idéologique et entame la
pérestroïka le gouvernement de rda
rejette résolument cette politique cette
inflexibilité contraste avec la vive
réaction de la population et la hausse
de l'activisme politique en 1989
l'europe orientale traverse une série de
révolutions de velours sous les slogans
de liberté
d'autodétermination et d'économie de
marché ce qui mènera à la chute du
régime communiste en pologne en hongrie
et en tchécoslovaquie
ces pays ouvrent leurs frontières avec
l'occident du coup les allemands de
l'est se précipitent par milliers pour
quitter la rda via leur territoire tout
cela amène la population à se mobiliser
de plus en plus activement pour réclamer
des changements à l'automne 89 les
événements s'accélèrent à la proche de
la date symbolique des 40 ans de la
fondation de la rda des manifestations
pour le changement inonde plusieurs
villes de l'est le 7 octobre
l'anniversaire de la fondation de la rda
mikhaïl gorbatchev effectué une visite à
berlin et entend la foule scandait
aide-nous gorby l'intensité de ce
mouvement populaire amène le
gouvernement est allemand à la démission
le nouveau chef de l'état egon krenz est
vite aux demandes de la population
il proclame la fin du monopole du parti
socialiste en rda ouvrant la voie aux
premières élections libres pourtant le
changement le plus important a mené par
le nouveau gouvernement et la chute du
mur de berlin le soir du 9 novembre le
porte parole du gouvernement annonce la
fin des restrictions de voyage depuis
l'est vers l'ouest pour les citoyens de
la rda il s'avère plus tard qu'il
s'agissait d'une erreur les nouvelles
règles ne devait pas être introduites
immédiatement cependant l'annoncé fait
l'effet d'une bombe des centaines de
milliers d'allemands des deux côtés font
sur la frontière sous la pression de la
foule les gardes sont forcés d'ouvrir le
passage le parti socialiste de la rda se
désintègre et en mars 1990 le parti
chrétien-démocrate gagne les élections
le même parti est déjà au pouvoir en rfa
de là il ne reste qu'un pas vers la
réunification de l'allemagne
en rfa le chancelier helmut kohl se
saisit du moment pour amorcer les
négociations sur la réunification avec
l'est en même temps débute les
pourparlers au format de +4 entre deux
allemagne et les quatre puissances
alliées de la seconde guerre mondiale
helmut khol parvient à convaincre le rss
à accepter que la future allemagne unis
soient membres de l'otan en échange de
l'aide économique le 12 septembre le
format de +46 le traité portant
règlement définitif concernant
l'allemagne ou traité de moscou le rss
accepte de retirer ses troupes de la rda
le 3 octobre les territoires de la rda
sont joints à la rfa et la rda cesse
d'exister la réunification des deux
allemagnes marque aussi la fin de la
guerre froide quel impact cette page de
l'histoire allemande aura-t-elle sur la
construction européenne dans les années
90 pour y voir plus clair nous revenons
vers henry ménudier professeur honoraire
des universités à paris iii sorbonne
nouvelle germanistes monsieur menuisier
quel a été le moment qui après
déterminer la réunification de
l'allemagne le régime politique
économique et sociale de la rda était à
bout de souffle au début des années 1980
de plus en plus allemands de l'ouest de
l'est partait se réfugier à l'ouest
l'économie se serait effondré sans les
prêts financiers de la république
fédérale la fragilité du régime a été
accentuée par les effets du contexte
international
à partir de 1981 1982 la révolution
solidarnosc qu'en pologne avec les
chevalets na a ébranlé le monde
soviétique mais également la r&d à la
pologne de la rda ayant une frontière
commune les réformes ensuite économique
et social de mikhaïl gorbatchev
à partir de 1985 c'est à dire la
pérestroïka et l'as north la sono sq ont
eu un très fort retentissement en rda
comme les dirigeants de berlin-est se
réfugier ce refus se refuser de faire
des réformes qu'il craignait de pouvoir
contrôler les citoyens de rda quitter
massivement le pays en 1989 pour réduire
cette pression la rd a décidé d'ouvrir
de mur de berlin le 9 novembre 1989
c'était le premier pas vers la
réunification de l'allemagne qui a eu
lieu le 3 octobre 1990 certains ex
allemands de l'est estiment qu'un mur
invisible existe toujours entre l'est et
l'ouest
êtes vous d'accord avec ça à partir de
s'effectue
immédiatement par l'intégration de la
rda d'un système politique économique et
sociale de la manne fédérale sans
période de transition donc cette
réunification a eu lieu très vite et
elle a beaucoup bousculé légèrement de
l'est il en résulte un effondrement
économique et une forte poussée du
chômage à l'est malgré l'aide financière
importante l'allemagne de l'ouest les
cas politiques économiques sociales et
culturelles persistent entre les deux
allemagnes il s'agit non seulement du
chômage mais aussi du niveau de vie des
salaires et de l'évolution démographique
les jeunes allemands de l'est par l
ouest pour y trouver des emplois
laissant à l'est une population
vieillissante et dont le nombre
d'habitants serait de se réduire on note
aussi d'importantes différences
politiques entre les deux allemagne les
partis fondés à l'ouest comme la cd ou
le spt le fdp et les verts sont moins
moins bien représentés en allemagne de
l'est qu'à l'ouest en revanche la gauche
août d-link aux racines communiste et
l'extrême droite la mt sont bien
implantés en allemagne de l'est donc
effectivement il ya bien une séparation
un mur invisible qui continue d'exister
entre les deux allemagnes merci beaucoup
monsieur ménudier je rappelle vous êtes
professeur honoraire des universités à
paris iii sorbonne nouvelle germanistes
merci pour cette analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]